how shocked are you to be sitting here
as the eliminated house guest
i am not shocked at all it makes
complete sense socially and game wise
i'm just proud that i got to walk
through that door the rest is game and
failure and uh i definitely can't wait
to learn from it by a vote of eight to
one
daniel you are evicted from the big
brother house you played the game and i
know you waited 10 years to play it
looking back though because obviously i
feel like your time in the house is
probably shorter than you wanted it to
be who do you feel the most betrayed by
at this point from what i'm learning you
know i'm being told that paloma was
going after me but i respect that like
it's part of the game i don't really
care like when you connect with someone
on a personal level you know if it's
reciprocated i'm on board the rest is
all game that's fine nicole's my homie
so i don't see any patrol even if she
says something bad about me i don't even
care i'm so interested to hear you say
paloma because i thought that was your
girl you must be starting to learn some
information are you kind of nervous to
find out some other info as you watch
the show back i'm not nervous i'm
looking forward to it because i have a
lot to learn from and a lot to grow from
but when it comes to paloma or nicole or
terrance people are jasmine people who i
was gung-ho 100
truly loyal to it'll be interesting to
see their perspective on the game or the
personal aspects on the show but also
when i talk to them in real life but
yeah so i'm looking forward to watching
the show for many reasons i feel like
you understand the game so you won't
take it personally is that a fair
assumption absolutely um
i tried to remove emotion when i went in
the game it didn't really happen so i'm
still gonna approach every episode every
live feed as strictly game and how it's
affecting their
overall um final to deal with anyone or
how they're getting to the end i can't
wait to see how they're doing it let's
talk about your eviction speech because
it was one for the book sir i mean it
was wrong thank you
houseguests please vote to evict me i
rather hang out with nicole and paloma
than any one of you bozos here today
this place is a circus and you're all a
bunch of clowns it's time to wake up and
realize michael has five competitions
under his belt it was really iconic i'm
not gonna lie i mean you told everyone
to vote you out you warned everyone
about michael i feel like at that point
you probably knew you were going to be
the one leaving so talk about that
strategy there what was the point well
the moment nicole left the house i knew
i was out next i said it out loud i knew
it was real we knew there was an
alliance that we called the sorry six
but you add kyle sorry seven now call
the leftovers so i had no numbers moving
forward no one had my back in the
nicollvo and i said i'm out next doesn't
make sense on the game level because i'm
only a social threat i'm not necessarily
a game threat because i don't have
numbers but that's a whole nother story
that i would spend an hour talking about
but yeah i think part of the speech is
true i think they're all clowns
including myself the other half is you
know just making sure that i throw uh
michael and monty under the bus because
they are some of the best players in
that house right and they're the ones
who are getting me out and i want to
make sure that they don't get to the end
because they are the best players there
and i think they will make it to the
final two if no one is paying attention
to it well speaking of speeches what did
you make of michael's veto speech and
using your words against you
to quote my favorite elvis impersonator
and what he said four weeks ago what's
good for the house is good for me
you've rubbed some people the wrong way
here and i hope you take this as an
opportunity to apologize daniel please
take a seat i respect it like you know i
don't hold anything against it he talked
to me yesterday before uh my eviction
and he apologized he's like you know i
don't i don't want to come off this
person i was like dude i respect all the
gameplay the speech and everything i
thought it was pretty funny and gold i
thought it was on point and you know
whether i believe it's true or not the
way he approached it it doesn't matter i
liked it i thought it was cool so on
your way out the door you only said
goodbye to terence why was that terence
is my boy uh we created the night shift
again i don't know what uh alliances are
aaron or not but me nicole terence in
the have not room created the night
shift and we were gonna go to the final
three together uh luckily as with nicole
my final two and since nicole left we
really doubled down on our friendship
it's only been growing since i put him
on the block so that meant the world to
me he kept me sane these last seven days
and actually sparked hope in me to
continue playing the game opposing just
uh giving up and he's the only one i
wanted to give my hug to and uh just
show my love to him everyone else i'll
see them in october not a big deal what
do you think his reaction to that hair
wax will be
i just assume he's gonna laugh because
we had our you know inside joke me him
and monty are inside you know connection
with that but ultimately it's like he
also doesn't have hair so it's a little
extra layer of laughter i think he'll
have a good laugh about it all right
let's talk about taylor because
obviously it seemed like you know most
of the house was against her at least at
the beginning of this competition she
was seemingly being blamed for a lot of
different things why do you think that
was oh i have no clue why
everyone was essentially against her or
wanting her out from the from the get-go
obviously my thing was when the paloma
thing happened on day six i believe and
on but before that i needed to make a
replacement and everyone was in my ear
except for nicole who's the only one
that was friends with her and supported
her i wanted to align with taylor that
first week until the paloma thing
happened but when you're living in the
house you know you get to know people
very quickly and people were rubbed the
wrong way with uh taylor's comments or
you know her cattiness or pettiness and
stuff like that that you're when you
live with someone you see those
immediately so when you first meet
people those are the little things that
you could go well this is why i want
them out i think taylor's a badass and
when you meet her you see it in her and
i think people are afraid of her um as
much as i was in the sense of her
winning the game winning then absolutely
killing it well now she's head of
household i don't know if you heard that
what yeah she won the competition so now
she's in charge what's your reaction to
that this that's what it is oh my god
yeah if i wasn't out this week i would
have been out right now
that's why i reacted as a fan i'm super
excited to watch it because that's wild
and i want to see what she does because
she did not like monty at least that's
what she told me for weeks but now she's
in this alliance and they've been
getting really close so i won if she
would take that shot or she's gonna
continue down the packing line of
whoever's not in the leftover so we'll
see i'm excited oh my god during your
interview with julie you uh said that
taylor lied about paloma can you expand
on that a little bit how so well what i
was told in the house i'm learning
different now was that she told monty
that paloma's coming after the guys and
monty was first on her list so however
that was twisted or misconstrued monty
came to me with that information so that
was a lie that came down and taylor
actually asked me a couple days ago why
am i your target i said i'm you're not
anymore you were initially because of
the paloma situation and taylor had
nothing to say to that so now hearing
this information i almost wish taylor
had said in that moment i hope you know
that that was all true and then we could
have talked about it but she doesn't owe
me anything so i respect that as well
looking back on that fight between you
nicole and taylor i will never forget
what you did at valoma
you think she didn't spiral because of
you you didn't add to that and now
you're trying to do it to nicole
mind games
guys
do not speak to nicole like that ever
again what ever again what's your take
on it now now that it's been a few weeks
and more information is coming out like
how do you see that whole incident now
ultimately in short i wish i could have
removed the emotion and approached it as
more of a house meeting if you will or
just having nicole and taylor in front
of me
because my emotions were high i wish i
could be like hey i'm not an hoh but i
need to know this so i can move forward
in this game
not emotionally you know it's
unfortunate to hear these news of me
mistaking what was said or maybe nicole
misheard but i have so much love and
loyalty to nicole i just trusted it 100
there's definitely better way to go
about it and when you're stuck in the
house the emotions definitely get the
best of you and i felt triggered in the
sense of i thought she was doing the
same thing that she did to paloma which
i'm learning is not necessarily true
anymore so it felt like oh she's double
downing on
what she did to my last ally so it was a
lot going through my mind and that's
that's where the last shot came from
opposed to stepping back and looking at
it from the outside it was nicole who
told me last week it's like it's just
that pressure cooker you know and it
kind of warps like what's really going
on at this point though do you still
blame taylor for paloma leaving i don't
blame her i told taylor to her face once
we were able to smooth things over a bit
which i'm sure wasn't aired but that i
don't think she was the reason i do
think it added to it and the only reason
that came to my mind was because taylor
said that to the house taylor said i may
have added to this and then that got
back to me so then it was a plant or a
seed in my head and that's how i felt
taylor initially said it herself and
that's how it got to me well last night
you said if you had done any wrongdoings
that you can't wait to write them
anything that comes to mind or maybe you
can speak on what you feel right now is
your biggest regret anything that had to
do with taylor i look forward to
watching back to learn who lied to me
and how it affected me or maybe people
weren't lying to me and i took it
differently and i will literally take
notes because
i want to actually be aware of what i'm
apologizing for when i talk to taylor
that is my priority and then of course
my approach to the outside world as far
as if i offended or her anyone family
friends of hers any my family friends
anyone i just want to make sure i am
aware of what i'm talking about opposed
to just saying it out loud i mean you
waited 10 years to be on big brother you
did it so it must feel good yes it does
ultimately yes it's been a dream come
true
[Applause]
[Music]
you